an alarming number of young people say
they've ridden in a car with an impaired
driver a new study shows one in three
recent high school grads admits being a
passenger in a car in the past year with
the driver who'd been drinking or taking
drugs twenty percent of them rode with
an alcohol impaired driver and 23
percent rode with the driver who used
marijuana our dr. Jon LaPook has
reported on the challenges of
determining if a driver is high on pot
the question so many people have John
good morning to see you so the study
looked at the transportation habits of
kids who were out of school a year or
two what did it find well it's
frightening these numbers right I mean
it turns out that they're 19 20 years
old and a third of them are driving in a
car with somebody who's impaired and
what's especially worrisome is that that
is a predictor for themselves in the
future driving while impaired and they
do it knowingly right because they bow
to peer pressure yeah it's tough to say
no right when everybody says come on you
know well you know what's the matter
what what are you afraid what do we what
do we know John about the impairment
drinking versus marijuana well you know
marijuana now a lot of study has been
done about this so it turns out and
there's there's a driving simulator out
in Iowa that I actually visited for my
piece for 60 minutes about 18 months ago
there's more weaving there's decreased
reaction time your judgment is impaired
and you actually may drive slower than
normally I spoke to one of the sheriff's
and he said that you know he pulled
somebody over for four suspected driving
while while stoned and the guy and the
guy said how fast was I going in the
sheriff said 10 miles an hour you know
that's really that can be very dangerous
they don't even know they're impaired
isn't that part of the problem well I
think with marijuana with cannabis they
suspect it more you know alcohol is more
they drive faster Romero marijuana
cannabis Mallett wants you well here is
the problem right so there are all these
states that are legalizing it two-thirds
of Americans think that recreational
marijuana should be should be legal and
so you know this is this is going on
there it's a national movement so if
you're gonna do that you want to do it
responsibly and one of the problems is
if a cop suspects that somebody's
driving while stoned pulls them over get
out of the car there's no equivalent of
the breathalyzer test that there is for
alcohol right they're developing it
there's some places that are trying but
it's not you
widely available so there they have to
look at things like your pulse your
blood pressure goes up your your pupils
maybe dilated you know wider than
normally and then you know finger nose
things like that
but the problem is that it gets out of
your bloodstream very quickly so by the
time they get to the police station to
get a blood test it may be significantly
lower growing acceptance at home doesn't
mean growing acceptance on the road what
do we do to bring these numbers down I
think education I think parents you know
you have to say to your kid my mother
and father said look if it's 3:00 in the
morning and you know you're drunk call
us we'll never yell at you for doing
that I think you have to make it sort of
a peer pressure thing that says I'm I
love you so much as a friend I'm not
gonna let you drive while impaired or be
in a car while with somebody who's
impaired and then of course these days
there are these car riding services you
know it's a lot easier well those are
key I mean we talk about on in one
segment the person being killed by a
driverless car right but at the same
time what benefit do uber car services
taxis in major metropolitan areas have
in addressing this yeah I think it can
be a huge benefit but I think the big
thing is a cultural shift at a time when
more and more people are thinking that
you know cannabis is safe that's the
general feeling and there needs to be
some educational governor Hickenlooper
who was in Colorado it's been legal
there for about five years and I spoke
to him about this problem there and he
said look they have to be guardrails you
have to have education it's you gonna do
it let's do it in a safe way and his big
thing that he was saying to states that
haven't yet legalized is go out and get
the information the data now about who's
driving while impaired who what cut
percentage of accidents have happened
with people who have cannabis in their
system because then if it gets legalized
you can compare before and after their
problem in Colorado is they don't they
have these statistics but it's going up
a little bit but is it because they're
looking more carefully you know the
studies have been very conflicting about
whether this has all changed the number
of accidents that are happening and all
of us have something we can talk about
again at the dinner table tonight
because you talk to your kids
very important